sonic the hedgehog is one of the most
iconic gaming heroes of our time
but how much about sonic and his
creation throughout the decades do you
know
here are 12 things about sonic the
hedgehog you might not know
while the original sonic the headshot
game had plenty of interesting zones
that would become
series staples such as green hill zone
or even the look and feel of spring yard
zone
which would basically evolve into casino
night zone there were a couple of
super interesting ones that never made
the final cut of these we have concept
art for a few with a much more
asian inspired feel one is a metallic
stage that is noted to have a gleaming
gold-plated landscape with the southeast
asian feel
likely with the working title gold world
zone
another concept art shows what we know
from an interview with naoto oshima
likely had the working title of chinese
world zone
and for reference many of the interviews
and some of the concept art are coming
from
this book sega mega drive genesis
collected works finally there's sonic
mountain slash underwater stage which
had japanese style rocky hills with
underwater sections
the illustration shows how the character
can spin to move across the surface of
the water
there will be various courses to choose
from dependent on skill
interestingly this idea of spinning the
bounce along the top of water
wasn't really ever incorporated except
from one single sonic game
game gear sonic 2 and aqua lake zone
meanwhile sonic's ability to run on the
top of water was first used in the hydro
city zone of sonic 3
and would frequently return in future
games something i personally find
interesting is that there's different
accounts about the start of sonic the
hedgehog
kotaro hayashida the creator sega's
first attempt to rival mario
alex kidd has one of the main differing
accounts in an interview in sega mega
drive
genesis collective works when asked if
he was disappointed that alex kidd
didn't last after sonic the hedgehog
he responds quote the idea to create
sonic was also mine
it is my understanding that a lot of the
ideas for sonic were inherited from what
might have been further alex kin
installments
it's pretty common knowledge that yuji
naka and naoto oshima are the two
co-creators of sonic the hedgehog
with yuji naka serving as the main
programmer and designer behind the games
and now to oshima serving as the artist
behind sonic the hedgehog himself
so this was a really weird find when i
first
read it kotaro hayashida goes on to
state that he created the initial
concept for the game
and set up a project to foster a
response to mario
given that yuji naka and naoto oshima
have both stated that they had a
prototype of sonic that they submitted
to sega higher ups to potentially be the
new mascot for sega
i have a feeling what really happened
was kotaro hayashida was the one who
proposed and set up a competition for a
new mascot
while yuji naka and naoto oshima were
the two actual creators whose concept
won out
when first working on sonic sonic wasn't
the hedgehog we all know and love
but rather a rabbit yujinaka's concept
for the game was based on his
experiences playing mario
he noticed that as he was playing mario
you could only speedrun the game at a
set speed once you mastered it
he wanted to make a far faster game
where people who improved could finish
courses faster and faster
as such the team thought a rabbit who's
traditionally considered a quick animal
was the right animal for the part
the gameplay included using the rapist
ears to pick up items and throw them at
enemies
the team wanted the game to be more
simplistic so they removed that element
and decided to look at other character
concepts outside of a rabbit
next was a bear concept who could curl
into a ball and roll which led them to
deciding to utilize either an armadillo
or
hedgehog thanks to naoto oshima's
hedgehog sketch known as mr needle mouse
a hedgehog would win out leading to the
sonic we now know
remember how i mentioned sonic's rabbit
prototype involved in picking up items
and throwing them at enemies with his
ears
well this very same prototype would be
repurposed four years later for a new
game in 1995
created by what would eventually become
known as sonic team
rystar which is a highly underrated game
that you should check out if you enjoy
platform games and have the time
sonic was made blue as his primary color
in order to match sega's corporate blue
logo
according to naoto oshima this was also
because in color psychology blue
signifies coolness and peacefulness
it also reflects my hope that the open
sky is blue forever
i made sonic's shoes red so that they
could be clearly seen when he begins to
run at high speed
sonic's design and overall attitude
takes inspiration from a variety of
famous pop culture figures
the first of these was michael jackson
who by the way will come up again later
in the list
sonic shoes were based on his boost from
the bad album meanwhile the red and
white was an inspiration
from none other than santa claus in fact
naoto oshima says his dream growing up
was to either be a cartoonist or to
become
santa claus so you can see how that
ended up serving as an inspiration
finally sonic's attitude was meant to be
based off of the united states then
president bill clinton's get it done
attitude
chili dog while sonic is known for his
attitude he originally had a whole lot
more which was either cut by sega of
america
or due to the limitations of technology
of the time and needing to save space
on the game's cartridge for one sonic
had a human girlfriend
so that infamous scene from sonico6
yeah that could have happened a lot
earlier this girlfriend was named
madonna and according to naoto oshima
sonic is smaller than a human but he had
a human girlfriend who is a very
attractive and would chase sonic
so it's like a male fantasy sega of
america
nixed this with then head of sega
america tom kalinski stating
our marketing team did a bunch of
revisions on the original japanese
character design so that it was
acceptable for the us market
he had a girlfriend named madonna with
this great cleavage we got rid of her
i think this will be one of the very few
times i say this
but for once i agree with marketing and
corporate over creative
sonic also had things which were removed
finally he was in a band where he would
be the lead singer
vector the crocodile on the keyboard
mock the rabbit on drums
max the monkey on base and sharps the
parakeet on guitar
according to madeline schroeder who's
been dubbed sega of america's mother of
sonic
sega of america removed this aspect
however this might have simply been
removed because it took up too much
space on the sega genesis cartridge
there is also even more meddling by sake
of america who presented the us version
of sonic the hedgehog's art to the sonic
team
while they absolutely hated it that's
the cover we got in the united states
regarding all of this yuji naka states
that in those days i
hated the american change to the look
and feel and i didn't know how the
consumers would perceive it
but looking back now that was one of the
reasons it succeeded sonic the hedgehog
was created as a collaboration between
programmer and designer yuji naka
visual designer naoto oshima and game
designer hirokazu yasuharu
however after its major success the team
actually split up to create two
completely different sonic games
yuji naka quit sega over various
disputes and moved to the united states
where he was convinced by mark cerny to
join his new company sti
other members of the original sonic team
joined him including hirokazu yasuharu
and the new sonic team now at sdi went
on to develop sonic 2 for the sega
genesis
meanwhile naoto oshima stayed in japan
where he became the project director on
a new sonic game for the sega cd
which would become sonic cd it utilized
the original sonic the hedgehog's code
as a bass
which is probably why sonic cd feels in
my opinion
closer to the original sonic than sonic
2 does it's fairly common knowledge at
this point that sonic 3 was only 50
percent of a complete game
originally yugi knock-in team tried to
create sonic 3 as a
3d game utilizing an svp chip
however this chip wouldn't be ready by
the time they needed it for development
deadlines
thus they were delayed in starting sonic
3 and only completed half of what they
wanted
so they put the rest of the game into
sonic and knuckles and yushinaka came up
with this lock-on technology
which would allow gamers to combine the
two games for one complete experience
what you might not know though is that
other sega games can be combined with
the cartridge for unique add-ons
for sonic 2 you could now play as
knuckles for games older than that you
play a special variation of the sonic 3
knuckles bonus stage
with a layout depending on the cartridge
sonic 1 allows you to play all of these
variations
yuji naka developed this additional
add-on ability completely in secret
with only his development department
knowing about it as they had to test for
bugs
even sega didn't know about this until
the game released
and yushinaka stated all along while i
was creating this trick
i was imagining the looks on children's
faces which made it really fun to do
these additional modes would eventually
be added to gamecube's sonic mega
collection
as the game titled blue
as i mentioned earlier sake of america
and the sonic team along with sega of
japan
didn't always get along and as sonic
became such a major property for the
company
everyone had their own input on what was
best for the series
and one such example comes from the
naming of tales in an internal
competition to create a sidekick for
sonic
yatsushi yamaguchi created the winning
character with tails
however there was a dispute over how to
name him sega japan was convinced miles
per hour
which would sound like miles per hour
was the best way to go
meanwhile sega of america wanted to name
the character tails
even writing a full backstory to the
character to try and convince everyone
that this name was best
finally yamaguchi found the compromise
by using both names
miles per hour would be his real name
and hills his nickname
that last factoid about tailsters is a
great springboard into
the sonic bible
this one's a little better known now
thanks to brian david gilbert's video on
just this topic
at some point allegedly an internal
documented sega of america was spread
a bible for all things related to sonic
the teams could cross-reference while
making future games
shows merchandise toys underwear
fan art oh oh
no what have these eyes seen
anyways this bible includes things like
sonic being born in hartley nebraska
which is different from even the recent
films green hill montana
his dad dying in toxic waste his name
actually being sunny
and his love for chili dog no
whopping beef gloppers what is this
blasphemy
do you like conspiracy theories
no not really i actually think they're
kind of annoying
what if they're true okay
now i'm on board whoa semi
true
it was long rumored that michael jackson
was involved in making the music for
sonic 3.
he was reportedly a huge fan of sega and
there was
of course a michael jackson video game
moonwalker
and thanks to a 2016 huffington post
article written by todd van luling
we now have evidence that's very likely
michael jackson was not
only a fan of sonic but was indeed
involved in helping write sonic 3's
soundtrack apparently the king of pop
decided to pay sti a visit as he was
such a huge fan of sonic 2
and wanted to meet the team behind it
apparently this led to him potentially
helping write the soundtrack to sonic 3.
according to three of the six accredited
songwriters on the game michael jackson
helped write the music
and they would produce high quality
renditions of part of the soundtrack
that would eventually be compressed for
the game
while michael jackson's team was
credited with helping contribute to the
soundtrack
according to them jackson was
disappointed with the compressed
versions of the songs
thus he pulled his name from the credits
according to howard drozen a
california-based composer
jerusalem was under the impression he'd
be working with michael jackson
but eventually told that he wouldn't be
around the time of the major scandal
that michael jackson had allegedly slept
with underage children
according to roger hector an executive
coordinator all the michael jackson's
music was pulled
or replaced meanwhile sega stated it
never worked with jackson on sonic 3 and
refuses to comment on the matter
it's interesting that so many of the
accredited musicians think that
jackson's work was in the game
which leads me to think that this might
actually be true
so there are 12 things you might not
have known about sonic the hedgehog
if you enjoyed this video let us know by
hitting the like button it really does
help
also let me know if you'd like to see
even more sonic the hedgehog facts
as with a 30 year history there is a lot
to cover
what are some of your favorite factoids
about sonic the hedgehog let me know in
the comments below and i'll see you guys
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you